we talked about the background is we
talked about chess.com last episode i
tweeted about it because i was even more
people loved that tweet dude that tweet
had tons of engagement
um it was good and the the summary of
this is that i actually we
underestimated it so chess.com gets
around 200 million monthly uniques they
have 60 million registered users they
traffic has grown significantly if i had
a guest they do at least 100 million in
recurring revenue subscription revenue
uh potentially is worth a billion
dollars super fascinating company um go
ahead what were you gonna say we were
trying to hype it and we actually were
under hyping even even though we were
trying to hype it um and by the way the
guy who started he's like an ex-stanford
guy or the guy who owns it it has two i
think stanford guys uh which is cool
like you know they didn't go the same
track probably as 95 of their classmates
and they're gonna outperform 99 of them
just by by doing something really simple
that the world wanted so i started
thinking about this because
we talked about it you brought it up
cool topic cool bit really cool business
it really fits the what we call the new
zealand type of business that andrew
wilkinson kind of coined that that
phrase which is
it's this independent thing
it has like a cult following it's
profitable it's simple
it's not nobody competes with it it's
like new zealand nobody's going to war
with with chess.com uh you know the
biggest competitor i think it's called
lie chess or something like that it's
basically like an open source free
you know like kind of like alternative
and it's also doing extremely well and
those are like the two uh but it seems
like people kind of prefer chess.com so
i started thinking okay
what's the nextchest.com what are the
others is there a whole slew of these
guys because i think that's where we
didn't talk about last time that we
should have and so i wanted to double
click in a little bit so i started
and that was that's a really really hard
question i've been thinking about it too
i only came up with like dominoes i
looked into solitaire websites they a
lot of them crush uh but yeah that's a
hard question to ask so i i spent 10 15
minutes on it but that was enough to
tell me something very interesting so
the first one that came to mind was
because here's the characteristics that
you need you need a game played by tens
of millions if not hundreds of millions
of people that is not owned by a brand
chess works
checkers also works but the problem with
checkers is it's so simple that it's not
as like uh there's not as much depth to
it therefore not as much of a like kind
of like uh money made and passion around
the sport uh sudoku was the second one
that came to mind so i went to
sudoku.com
and sudoku.com
it's just like chess.com it's like you
you go to snooki.com and there's already
a sudoku board waiting for you with
clock going and it's like oh play here
it is you don't need to download you
don't need to sign up you don't need to
do anything just play sudoku i love that
then they you scroll down a little bit
and you see like this advertisement for
like a mobile app a mobile sudoku app so
i clicked that i'm like i bet this app i
bet this is an amazing distribution for
this app
app crushes so this company called
easybrain behind it
so the sudoku app that they have has 50
million downloads
the uh on just google play forget about
iphone that's just google that's just
android um it's probably 100 million
total lifetime downloads the website
itself gets you know 10 to 20 million
visitors a month uh so they're getting
free tr basically free traffic to their
mobile apps where they're able to
monetize and easy brain basically makes
they're like a mobile app developer that
makes these apps they've had over 750
million downloads lifetime of these
little simple number game apps starting
with sudoku then like a remix of sudoku
then like another number game if you
like that one and they just cross
promote them within each other
i bet this company is crushing it
they're based in europe and looks like i
have information on on them i just found
some interesting stuff when i googled
them and went to the website there was
something amazing about them that
immediately stuck out
and and just this quick google it i'm
wrong but
it
is based in cyprus any time a company is
based in cyprus
it's like
it's turns out these guys actually are
uh from like the belarus they're
actually from this area but they're
based in cyprus so i'll i just googled
it real quick so uh did you know that it
was they were acquired um
three months ago no i did not know this
so that's okay that's the other piece
i have their revenues i have their
profit and i have the uh all their user
numbers and i have can i guess
i'm going to be totally wrong but i i
like to guess by the way little tip
always guess before you hear any number
that's how you get good at knowing
numbers because you guess and then when
you're wrong your brain remembers that
and you start to hone that gut
instinct okay so here's here's my guess
okay well uh how much were they what
what's their revenue i'm gonna guess
that their revenue was 400 million
dollars a year
okay what's their um profit
90 million dollars a year
pretty good um all right how much were
they required for
i'm gonna guess that they're required
for
852 million dollars
okay and how many um
how many
daily active users do they have across
their 15 games
i'm going to say they have
25 million dau
okay so you didn't do you didn't do
horrible okay so easy brain was acquired
uh last this most recent february uh
they were uh acquired for 640 million
dollars in stock and up to 120 million
dollars of additional consideration if
they hit it so 640 yeah what is that
that isn't that exactly 850
no what's six uh what 640 plus 100 is
740 plus 25 is
so
great job you guessed 8.50 great job
you're almost there um they their
revenue is uh in 2020 revenues were 210
million dollars okay so you were off
there by half you guessed 400 million
but their profit was 70 million you
guessed 90. right pretty good um they've
had 750 installs over the course of
their the lifetime of all their other
things all their games they have uh 15
live games with 12 million daily active
users you guessed 25 million okay not
bad not bad um what a company so okay so
that was the first one i thought of and
by the way i think that there's other
versions of that like you know i don't
know go look at like you know
sudokuonline.com i don't know what's
that like you know all the things people
are gonna google search if you can get
the top level domain for those that's
really interesting um so then i started
looking at some others
poker.com so i went to poker.com and
poker.com is like kind of like this
crappy like just describe what you're
looking at when you go to it
let me look at this but you can't this
is an actual poker right
you're not betting
it's not even a as you can't play there
it's just like
reviews here's it it's like an affiliate
site so it's like oh here's a place to
play poker here's where you go because
they get big kickbacks for basically
sending a player to poker stars or
wherever if they deposit and so this is
horrible website um crappy kind of like
affiliate reviews site dude you could do
so much more with this website like if
somebody was like dude i'm gonna i have
a if you have a mobile poker app that's
like good
i would pay like ungodly amounts of
money for poker.com i think that that's
a and they also if you like do their
traffic search see what they get it's
nothing
so they should be getting a lot more
traffic having poker.com um okay so then
there's some other ones
crosswordpuzzle.com crossword.com
go to this like they don't even like
crossroads.com or something doesn't even
like render it's like a there's like fun
on the screen yeah like what's going on
here because crossword is the other game
that's like sudoku it's like chess that
people
played religiously and they love we
talked about how how much the new york
times makes off their mini crossword
game
the number was uh
90 million dollars in subscription
revenue from crossword puzzles for the
new york times
so so i am surprised at crossword puzzle
across the puzzles.com crossword.com i
can't believe that these sites are not
being like leveraged so i was very
surprised to see this and uh
yeah this follow up from this so you go
to crosswoodpuzzle.com
it says please email suggestions to
dkw999
yahoo.com right so i i emailed the guy
so
so so you see this the website is
basically like a white page with a bunch
of text and it's basically just the very
bottom things
the very bottom it says this dome note
this domain is not for sale please do
not inquire about purchasing it all
emails from anonymous are unknown
companies asking me a price will be
ignored sorry last updated july 2007
right so i emailed this guy i was like
hey uh saw your website
um
[Music]
like i think it's awesome that you're
not trying to sell this but i'm curious
like why aren't you trying to sell this
and uh what's your you know what do you
want this to be why do you believe like
why do you believe that it should be
done this way you know i'm just super
curious like what's your thought problem
so we'll see if he replies
[Music]
you